well met brave heroes and heroines of
the world today we've got a list of our
favourite hero in training midoriya
azúcar from the anime my hero academia
with season 4 on its way I thought now
would be a good time to talk about some
of the best moments that our boy
midoriya has had and to see how far he's
come so break out the mobs to wipe away
your waterfalls of tears because we're
about to start
to start off the list we show midoriya
being put through the quirk apprehension
test once they get accepted into the you
a hero course of class 1a the students
are given a test to assess their various
unique quirks and show what they're
capable of eventually it's our boy dake
who's turned to take the test as an
unimpressed Eraserhead watches on but
after inheriting the awful one quote
from his idol almighty Beck who was
finally able to literally hurl the heavy
ball out of the park it left all of his
fellow classmates in or even a race
ahead without a doubt Midori approved
that he has hero potential
since it
[Music]
ha go get it
[Music]
ix moment is the tag-team match between
team deco and Urraca
versus team buck will go and EDA this
moment showed some good old-fashioned
school rivalry taken to an octane level
as their COO and Oaxaca are made as the
heroes in a scenario where they stop the
villains EDA and Barker go from
fulfilling their evil plan and seizing a
fake bomb from them in a tight team
exercise the seeds a game of Search and
Destroy as Baku go hateful he calls out
to Deku about how he hid his quark to
mock him and show him up during their
snake who doesn't personally attack
barking over instead with some quick
thinking makes his rival use his quirk
so that they can retrieve the fake bomb
just goes to show you that the brain is
a superpower in and of itself
suited
[Music]
no matter how bad a situation looks a
true hero will always turn back to save
a fallen comrade in death whose case he
got firsthand learning experience of
this during the entrance exam the
students had to take on several giant
robots to show how their quirk can be
applied in the field to determine
whether or not they'll get into either
of the u-ace hero courses for the most
part midoriya stayed clear of the robots
as he wasn't supposed to reveal his
newly acquired quirk just yet and for
awhile he managed to keep this up but
then his schoolmate irako got caught
under some rubble and couldn't get away
from an attacking robot Bek who saw this
and remembering how nice she was to hear
when they all first entered the school
threw caution to the wind and used his
quote for the first time ever just to
save his friend it left everyone in all
that this chicken heart of a team packed
so much power and while he messed up his
arm badly it was an amazing save
nevertheless
fish too obscure
to fret us the next moment let me ask
you all this have you ever faced someone
so intimidating both physically and
mentally that you felt your heart
stopped when your eyes met one another
that was the situation as midoriya
Todoroki and EDA fort stain while there
who has a reputation for leaping before
he looks if he decides to look at all
that is it was actually the usually
sensible EDA who sought out the infamous
hero killer that is stained his plan was
to get revenge on staying for crippling
his older brother and short time hero
Tensei AKA in guinea 'm and that whole
encounter went as well as you would
expect at first it seemed like they were
gonna die but together the heroes in the
making actually managed to subdue stain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a hero's duty to save everyone
including fellow heroes and that's no
different for a hero in training while
the pro heroes were busy working out a
plan on how to save beaucoup go after
the League of villains kidnap tip
midoriya made the executive decision
that the heroes in training should
rescue him now of course everyone took
sides of whether to go with him or
whether to stand back and let the pros
handle it in the end it was midoriya eda
momo Kirishima and Todoroki who went on
a suicide mission in order to save their
temperamental friend things got serious
as deku and friends realized what they
got themselves into fortunately however
they actually did manage to save buck
we'll go in the end
the students of UA were given a
practical test in which they pan up in
teams of two to fight one pro hero per
team to improve their teamwork and show
how far they've come individually this
made for some unique matchups but the
match we're talking about is Daegu and
Baku go versus all might now the
analytical deck who wanted to make a
plan to hang up the pro hero without
much need for battle but headstrong buck
will go once again shot off without
taking aim and just started fighting to
his credit but Google did make an effort
or be at a regretting one to win the
practical test only for it to come up
short and result in him getting beaten
down pretty badly at that point there
who made the decision to win by taking
the escape route than trying to subdue
the pro who clearly had them outclassed
and with an amazing kit of everything
that he has midoriya managed to save his
rival and take the escape route giving
them the past that they needed
the highlight of the sports festival art
was seeing Todoroki and deku come to
blows in their match for a shot at the
semi-finals the teen starts off
relatively slow with it being obvious
that Todoroki is holding back not
wanting to unleash his flame sight as he
doesn't want to be like his estranged
father endeavor but encouraging words
from their COO telling him that he's his
own person make Todoroki unleash the
full force of his other side winning him
the match he encourages Todoroki to use
his full power to get over his mental
issues and grow as a person and this
opposes his personal goal of the moment
to win the match but it serves the
greater goal of having a peaceful world
by helping the Allies grow as heroes
middle you
this scene comes straight from the movie
my hero academia two heroes which has
our class of budding protectors smack
dab in the United States facing a new
threat with the help of all mites old
friend David shield and his daughter
Melissa without giving away too many
spoilers in case you haven't seen the
movie deku and all might pair up towards
the end of the film to deliver a
devastating tag-team blow that is the
double detroit smash combo while it was
just one seed it nonetheless gave us the
or inspiring predecessor and protege
team-up we've always wanted to see
between the symbol of peace and young
midoriya
[Music]
this takes place after the episode we're
all might defeated all for one and
announced his retirement whilst he's not
a super fan boy like midoriya it's
obvious that bubu go greatly admires the
symbol of peace and when he retired and
chose Deku to continue his legacy he was
pissed the teenage personification of
rage said it was Dec whose fault that
almighty retired and demanded a fight to
see what made him so special to continue
his legacy this episode would become the
starting point of but who goes much
needed Redemption art from an
antagonizing rival to a relatively
likeable ally and given how midoriya
always looked up to him I'd say this is
a top moment indeed
the final moment is an anxiety fueling
yet still satisfying fight of deku
versus muscular this fight happened
during the forest training camp park in
which the league of villains attack the
hero Corps students at the special
training site have raised a head and
Vlad King took them to as sadistic as he
is strong muscular openly admitted that
he wants to use his muscle augmentation
quirk freely for the purpose of killing
so off the bat Deku wasn't going to have
an easy fight and with young Kota in the
way adding to the risk factor that makes
the stakes even higher
Deku initially seems like you lose to
the brawny villain but thanks to his
destruction from Kota the hero in
training manages to take muscular out
with his Delaware Detroit smash and
tears right through the meatheads
muscles
I'm conducting our
[Music]
welcome
and with that folks we now wrap up the
video I hope you enjoyed going down
memory lane as much as I did if you want
to see more of my hero academia content
on this channel then like this video and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already you can maybe even follow me on
social media by following the respective
links in the description box as well
I've been all a plus ultra farewell